-The president's lawyer went on
TV and basically admitted
that his campaign might have
colluded with Russia.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Every day, it gets harder to
defend Trump's actions
in the Russia investigation
which is why Trump
cycles through more lawyers
than a "Law & Order" marathon.
"Oh, hey, that guy was a jogger
three episodes ago."
[ Laughter ]
In fact, this week, Trump's
nominee for Attorney General
William Barr was grilled
by Senators
at his confirmation hearing
about the fact
that Trump
originally wanted Barr
to be his private criminal
defense attorney,
which would be an obvious
conflict of interest.
But Barr said he met with Trump
once
and then never heard back
from him.
-It was a very brief meeting
where essentially the president
wanted to know -- he said,
"Oh, you know Bob Mueller.
How well do you know Bob
Mueller?"
I told him how well I knew Bob
Mueller,
and he was interested in that,
wanted to know, you know,
what I thought about
Mueller's integrity and so forth
and so on.
And I said,
"Bob is a straight shooter
and should be dealt with
as such."
So he asked me
for my phone number.
I gave it to him, and I never
heard from him again.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's obvious why.
I mean, we've all seen
Trump's tweets.
I mean...
what are the odds he wrote down
a phone number correctly?
[ As Trump ] Yeah, dial this --
213-55K-crying-emoji-8.
[ Laughter ]
What do you mean
it's not ringing?
[ Normal voice ] So Barr didn't
want to be Trump's lawyer.
No respectable lawyer does.
That's why Trump is stuck with
outer borough ambulance chasers
like Rudy Giuliani.
Although Rudy doesn't really
look like he chases ambulances.
They probably just follow him
when he goes out for a walk.
[ Laughter ]
But apparently --
[ Applause ]
But apparently, even Rudy is
having a hard time with the job,
especially as
Special Counsel Robert Mueller
prepares to issue
his final report.
"Vanity Fair" reported yesterday
that Rudy fears that the report
will be horrific for Trump
and that the mounting pressure
has also strained Giuliani's
relationship with Trump.
"Rudy hates the job.
Trump is very hard
to deal with."
Oh, you're just
finding that out now?!
[ Laughter ]
Come on, Rudy,
you went into this job
with your eyes wide open,
and I do mean wide open.
[ Laughter ]
You look like you just saw
a pretty lady in an old cartoon.
[ Ah-oogah! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
We spent a lot of time
on that today.
[ Laughter ]
And it really does seem like
the pressure of the job
is getting to Rudy
because last night,
he went on CNN and blurted out
another one of his trademark
accidental confessions.
Rudy was interviewed
by CNN's Chris Cuomo,
and the way these two yelled at
each other was like watching
two guys play cards
in the back of a butcher shop.
-They hated Trump. Hated.
-"Hate"'s your word.
But clearly --
-No, when you say that a man --
-But the Inspector General,
two of them,
said it didn't affect
their work.
-You think it's fair?
-I wouldn't want to be
investigated by anybody,
and it was the right move
to remove them.
No, they didn't.
-By the time they were finished.
-Yes, they did.
They don't pay any attention
to the platform.
-I was raised by a guy who would
have corrected the punctuation
in the party platform.
I'm saying that, that was --
-Chris, let me explain --
-The guy was the head
of the A.G. at the time
was his campaign guy.
-I'm hyperactive
about the probe.
Chris, let's be truthful.
Let's be truthful.
-Always. Always.
-Come on, now.
-Mom!
The only thing missing
from that conversation
was a few salami rolls
hanging on strings.
[ Laughter ]
That interview should have had
a voiceover from Ray Liotta.
[ Indistinct arguing ]
-As far back as I could
remember,
I always wanted
to be a gangster.
-And that was all --
That was, like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was, like, not even
a minute into it.
Rudy starts every interview
like he's in hour five
of a police interrogation.
"I want to welcome
our next guest, Rudy Giuliani.
-You got me! I'll tell you
everything you want to know!
And then Cuomo asked Rudy
about the latest bombshell
in the Russia investigation.
Trump campaign's chairman Paul
Manafort
shared political polling data
with a business associate
tied to Russian intelligence,
and that's when Rudy
made a stunning claim.
He never said the campaign
didn't collude with Russia,
just that Trump himself
didn't collude with Russia.
-Now you have Paul Manafort
giving poll data --
-I never said --
-That winds up leading to
this coincidence.
-Well, you just misstated
my position.
I never said there was no
collusion between the campaign
or between people
in the campaign.
-Yes, you have.
-I have no idea -- I have not.
I said the President
of the United States.
He said he didn't.
He didn't say nobody.
How would you know that
nobody in your campaign --
-He actually did say that,
Rudy. He said nobody.
-Well, I never said that.
>> And then he said,
"As far as I know."
-If he said that, he said it
in -- Well, as far as he knows,
that's true!
-Look at him!
[ Laughter ]
Even he looks surprised
by what he just said.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Either that, or he's got a
binder clip behind his head
pulling back all of his skin.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like a grandpa
at a theme park
who didn't realize how fast
the roller coaster was.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, also, also -- yes.
You did say
there was no collusion
and you didn't say it
once or twice.
You said it a bunch of times.
-Russian collusion.
Here's what they found.
Zero. Nada. Nothing.
If anything, it's proof
there was no collusion.
Nobody talked about Russians.
Nobody knew about Russians.
There was no collusion
with the Russians.
No collusion with the Russians.
There was no collusion.
There was no Russian collusion.
No Russian collusion. Case over.
Was there collusion? Come on.
Nobody believes anymore
there was collusion.
-Think about how much their
argument has changed.
It went from there were
no contacts with Russians
to there was no collusion
with Russians
to we tried to collude,
but nothing came of it
to collusion is not a crime
to there was collusion,
but it didn't involve Trump.
If this keeps going, Rudy
is going to be telling Trump,
"It's not jail,
it's a gated community."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now...
We don't -- We don't know.
We don't know exactly what
Trump's level of involvement was
in collusion, but we do know
that as a politician
and president,
Trump has always admired
Russian President Vladimir Putin
and sought to emulate him.
Even before he ran
for president,
he was desperate to
be Putin's friend.
-Do you have a relationship
with Vladimir Putin,
a conversational relationship?
-I do have a relationship.
I spoke indirectly and directly
with President Putin
who could not have been nicer.
I was in Moscow
a couple months ago.
I own the Miss Universe pageant.
And they treated me so great.
Putin even sent me a present.
Beautiful present
with a beautiful note.
-[ As Trump ] It was a beautiful
note, handwritten,
and it was delivered by a raven
in the middle of the night.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just tapped...
his beak, you know, his beak
tapped, and that woke me up.
[ Normal voice ]
And we also know that Trump
has had all kinds of business
entanglements with Russians
and Putin, in particular,
including the fact that
as late as the summer of 2016,
he was in talks with Putin to
build a Trump Tower in Moscow.
He was even going to
entice Putin
by giving him an apartment
in the building.
-One of the ideas for that
Trump building,
according to one of his business
associates,
was to give the top floor,
the penthouse apartment
in a 250-apartment block,
to Vladimir Putin,
the Russian president,
as a way of attracting buyers.
-Trump's plan was to attract
buyers by telling them
you get to live in the same
building as Vladimir Putin.
Can you imagine what it would be
like to have Putin
as your upstairs neighbor?
[ Russian accent ] Hello,
would you mind
turning down your music?
Otherwise I poison your dog.
[ Laughter ]
"Okay. I see you
at co-op meeting!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Trump repeatedly denied
he had any sort of business
relationship with Russia,
but that line changed
once we found out
about the deal to build
a Trump Tower in Moscow.
Trump said, "If I did do it,
there would have been
nothing wrong."
But there would have been
something wrong.
It would have violated
the Constitution.
There's a section
of the Constitution
called the emoluments clause
that specifically forbids
the president from taking gifts
from foreigners.
And we know that because
during the election,
Donald Trump supporters kept
saying Hillary was breaking it.
-Every foreign gift,
every foreign speech
while she was...
-It's a big charge.
-...Senator or Secretary of
State, every one --
No, it's not a big charge.
It's the U.S. Constitution.
There's a section
in the Constitution
called the emoluments clause.
It says,
"No one, nor their spouse
can take money from foreigners."
She has to be guilty
of 70 or 100 counts
just on that one charge.
-You think Hillary's guilty
because she had a foundation
that gave out malaria shots
to kids in Africa?
Trump had a charity,
and he used it to buy
two portraits of himself.
Although when it comes
to Trump portraits,
this remains my favorite.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Look at that, the difference
between that portrait
and the actual Donald Trump
is like the difference
between Spider-Man in the comics
and the Spider-Man
in Times Square.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's the difference between
the Big Mac in the commercial
and the one you actually get
in your drive-through bag.
[ Laughter ]
And on top of that,
Trump and Putin have had
several private meetings
with no one else in attendance.
And we have no idea what they
discussed in those meetings.
The only people who do know
are the Russians
thanks to note-taking practices
they developed
during the Soviet era.
The "Washington Post"
reported yesterday
the United States
has no detailed record
of Trump's five face-to-face
interactions with Putin
over the past two years.
Russia, on the other hand,
almost certainly does.
The interpreters working
for Soviet leaders
were trained to take nearly
verbatim stenographic notes.
Can you imagine how hard it is
to take verbatim stenographic
notes of Donald Trump?
Even closed captioning
has a hard time
following what he's saying.
-God bless
the United Schtates.
Thank you very much.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's why --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's why their argument
keeps changing.
They don't have an argument,
and the reality
is slowly sinking in.
Trump can say he didn't know
he was colluding with Putin
because Putin hypnotized him,
and Rudy would say --
-As far as he knows,
that's true!
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪